y las cámaras de seguridad captaron el
momento el tráfico avanzaba normalmente
hasta que ocurrió la tragedia a las 10
de la noche hora de ciudad de mexico se
dio una vía elevada del metro debido al
colapso los vagones cayeron a la
carretera desde una altura de 5 metros
la alcaldesa de la ciudad de mexico
explicó que una viga se rompió mientras
pasaba el convoy
quiero decirles a los familiares si me
están escuchando si no tienen la
suposición de que alguno de sus
familiares venía en el tren hay aquí un
área de atención y está también en cada
uno de los hospitales
las autoridades confirmaron más de 20
muertos y cifraron en decenas los
heridos muchos de ellos hospitalizados
en situación grave las unidades de
rescate continúan buscando
supervivientes entre las ruinas
la búsqueda fue interrumpida porque el
tren partido por la mitad colgaba
peligrosamente pero una grúa permitió a
los equipos de emergencia continuar
buscando a los supervivientes
el accidente ocurrió en la línea 12 del
metro cerca de la estación olivos
construida en 2012 mientras el actual
secretario de exteriores
marcelo ebrard era alcalde de la ciudad
entre las primeras hipótesis el colapso
en la línea más nueva de ciudad de
mexico podría estar causado por defectos
de construcción relacionados con la
corrupción